We now hopefully know a little about variables
and as we covered in the last video, a variable can be
really any symbol, although we typically use letters
because we're used to writing and typing letters.
But it can be anything from an x, to a y, a z, an a, a b,
and oftentimes we start using greek letters like theta.
But you can really use any symbol to say
Hey, this is going to vary
You can take on multiple values
But out of all of all of these
The one that is most typically used in algebra
Or really in all of mathematics
is the variable "x"
Although all of these are used to some degree
But given that x is used so heavily
it does introduce a slight problem.
And that problem is that it looks a lot like the multiplication symbol
Or the one that we use in arithmetic
So in arithmetic
if I want to write 2 x 3
I literally write "2 x 3"
But now that we are starting to use variables,
if I want to write "2 times x"
Well if I use this as the multiplication symbol
it would be 2 times x
And the times symbol and the X
look awfully similar
and if I'm not really careful with my penmanship
it can get very confusing.
Is this "Two x x"?
Is this "two times times something"?
What exactly is going on here?
And because this is confusing,
This, right over here, is extremely confusing
And it can be misinterpreted,
We tend not to use this multiplication symbol
When we are doing algebra
Instead of that, to represent multiplication,
We have several options.
Instead of writing two times x this way,
we could write 2 dot x.
And this dot, I want to be very clear,
This is not a decimal
This is just written a little bit higher
And we write this so we don't get confusion
in between this and one of these variables right here.
But this can really be interpreted as "2 times x"
So for example, if someone says
2 dot x, when x is equal to 3,
well this would be the same thing
as two times three, when x is equal to three.
Another way you could write it is
You could write "2" and then you could write the x in parentheses
right next to it.
This is also interpreted as 2 times x
Once again, so in this situation
If "x" were seven, this would be
two times seven, or fourteen
And the most traditional way of doing it
is to just write the x right after the 2.
And sometimes this will be read as "2x"
But this literally does mean "Two times x"
And you might say, how come we didn't always do that?
Well it would be literally confusing if we did it over here.
Instead of writing "2 times 3"
And wrote "2 3"
Well, that looks like "23".
This doesn't look like two times three
And this is why we never did it.
But here, since we're using a letter now,
It's clear that this isn't a part of that number.
This isn't "twenty something"
This is two times this variable x.
So all of these are really the same expression.
Two times x, two times x, and two times x.
And so with that out of the way
Let's try some few worked examples, a few practice problems
And this will hopefully prepare you for the
next exercise
Where you'll get a lot of chances to practice this.
So if I where to say "what is 10 minus three y"
And what does this equal when "y" is equal to two
Well, every time you see the "y"
You'd want that 2 there
So this is y is equal to 2.
Let's set that y equal to two
This is the same thing as 10 minus three times two
You do the multiplication first.
Multiplication takes precedence in order of operations
So three times two is six,
Ten minus six is equal to four.
Let's do another one.
Let's say we had "7x minus 4"
And we want to evaluate that when
when x is equal to three.
Where we see the x, we want to put the 3 there
So this is the same thing as "7 times 3"
And I'll actually use this notation, so seven times three minus four.
And once again, multiplication takes precedence
by order of operations, over addition or subtraction
So we want to do the multiplying first
7 times 3 is 21
21 minus 4 is equal to 17.
So hopefully that gives you a little bit of background,
and I really encourage you to try the next exercise,
It will give you a lot of practice
on being to evaluate expressions like this.